the cultists screamed the long and
spindly but unimaginably powerful arm of
the shy guy had him by the leg dragging
him backwards his fingernails carving
deep rots into the floor his friend was
already on the run but his death warrant
had been sealed by a glance in the
history of evil plans rarely has an evil
plan backfired so spectacularly as the
shy guy bellowed destroying its latest
prey in Galloping after the second which
would soon become the third and the
fourth and the fifth and so much more as
the Personnel of the SCP Foundation
caught unplanned glimpses of his
terrible face it would take a God to
undo the chaos that was unfolding the
exact same God that these two idiot
cultists were here to destroy the plan
had seemed so simple so perfectly
straightforward on paper sneak in to the
SCP Foundation and assassinate
scp-343 that being said even deluded
cultists of the Scarlet King knew that
killing the anomaly believed to be God
himself was going to be far easier in
theory than in practice and yet neither
one of this Intrepid pair of foundation
impersonators could ever have predicted
things would go this bad several years
earlier Zachary and cash were nothing
more than a pair of social shut-ins
trolling forms on the internet from the
secluded sanctuary of their basements in
fact it was on a particular one of these
forums that would lead to the pair
eventually meeting in person periwatch a
deep web online space for discussions of
the supernatural while there was nothing
inherently Insidious about parawatch
itself it did draw on those who were
interested in the Paranormal and even
the anomalous like Zack and cash and
that made the 4 the perfect recruitment
tool for those whose intentions were far
more nefarious both men were
individually approached by another user
who was only known by his screen name
cot SK over some lengthy conversations
with this mysterious third party both
Zack and cash found themselves being
convinced into believing the core tenets
of a murderous cult that revered a
conceptual deity the children of the
Scarlet King and it was during a secret
Gathering of their fellow members that
cash and Zach would not only meet but
find themselves specifically tasked with
a mission that was meant to clear the
way for the Scarlet King to enter our
reality simply put the two of them were
tasked with killing God the plan was
devised by one of the longer standing
Children of the Scarlet King who
divulged their cult's knowledge of the
SCP Foundation specifically an entity
known as scp-343 a a powerful reality
warper who had claimed to be the
architect of the very universe itself in
the eyes of the Scarlet King's followers
this meant that scp-343 could pose a
direct threat to the Ascension of their
destructive deity if the Scarlet King
was ever to gain access to this universe
there was a high chance
scp-343 could oppose him so with stolen
credentials and Foundation Personnel
Garb Zack and cash were sent into remove
scp-343 from the equation it goes
without saying that killing a being
believed to be God himself was hardly an
easy goal to achieve nobody could just
poison the scp-343 or taken out using
Conventional Weapons or even use any
other typical methods of assassination
that would work on a human target
instead Zack and cash needed to get
creative luckily there was another
anomaly kept contained by the SCP
Foundation that the children of the sky
Charlotte King had thought would be
perfect for the job it was a miniature
Event Horizon a black sphere that could
pull any nearby matter into itself
anything brought within the vicinity of
this anomalous Wormhole would quickly be
sucked in and ultimately lost forever
with no chance of retrieval sure it
might not kill scp-343 strictly speaking
but it could certainly remove him from
play leaving the universe unprotected
against the rise of the Scarlet King
however there was one tiny problem one
otherwise minute detail that because it
went uncorrected jeopardized the whole
plan it could have been down to
inaccurate information that the children
of the Scarlet King had on the SCP
Foundation after all the organization
was known for keeping its operations and
even its very existence a closely
guarded secret or perhaps surely due to
human error the wrong number was said by
the wrong cultist at the wrong moment
Miss heard or misread leading to a four
being replaced with a six you see the
miniature Event Horizon was designated
as
scp-094 but by mistake Zack and cash had
slipped undetected into the foundation
in search of
scp-096 unaware that anomaly was far
from what they were expecting the look
of Terror on Zack's face appeared
instantly as the pair of scarlet King
Fanatics opened the door to the
containment cell that same horrified
look had vanished just as quickly the
second that scp-096 took notice of the
two new visitors in the blink of an eye
the abnormally proportioned humanoid
anomaly had gone from being hunched over
in a corner gently rocking itself to
standing directly in front of Zach and
cash towering over them both and
screeching incoherently cash turned and
ran abandoning his cultist compatriot as
Zach screamed in fear the shy guy had
grabbed him a moment later his screams
had been silenced thanks to
scp-096 cash had no idea what the
creature was all he knew was it
certainly wasn't the miniaturized black
hole he and Zach had been sent to find
but he tried to keep the original goal
in mind even in a moment of Crisis take
out scp-343 so that the Scarlet King
could rise maybe this other anomaly
whatever it was could stand a chance
against the reality warper cash would
never get to find out however as he was
tackled To The Ground by a foundation
security team as he turned the corner
but scp-096 had been hot on the cultists
heels and that appeared behind him just
as he was being restrained by security
officers and the whole unit could see
the shy guy now which meant not one of
them stood a chance meanwhile elsewhere
in the facility oblivious to the Carnage
of the unfolding containment rate
scp-343 was enjoying a stroll around the
foundation site with a hamburger in one
hand and a milkshake in the other he had
spent most of the afternoon the way he
usually did phasing out of reality to an
extra dimensional astral plane outside
of our known universe where he could
privately enjoy a game of Solitaire
using a deck of cards conjured out of
nothingness Upon returning polishing off
the dregs of his lunch which he also
willed into existence from nowhere
scp-343 barely noticed that the entire
Foundation seemed to be on Red Alert or
more accurately he did notice he just
didn't do much to help you see one of
the more notable things about scp-343
aside from the fact that he can use his
anomalous abilities to do literally
anything imaginable is that he very much
enjoys taking a back seat he claims that
after creating the universe he got tired
of having to be in control of everything
everywhere all at once good movie by the
way and so while SCP e343 could right
every wrong and solve every problem in
the entire universe he chooses not to
all to pursue the illusion of giving up
control and leaving the universe to its
own devices that is unless something
tries to harm him directly and something
was very much about to while the pair of
scarlet King cultists who had
accidentally set
scp-0963 were already dead they'd
unknowingly started a chain reaction the
foundation desperately dispatched more
of its Personnel to try and recontain
the shy guy but the more they sent the
more of them observed the creature this
gave
scp-096 even more targets extending its
rage State as it zipped through the
foundation killing everyone that had
clasped eyes on it until that ragefield
Rampage led to coincidentally cross
paths with scp-343 would just walked
through a wall on his way back to his
cell right into the path of scp-096
oh dear dearly
scp-343 side finishing the remainder of
his milkshake before making the empty
cup and straw disappear it's been some
time hasn't it Ian my boy look at what's
become for a moment
scp-096 seemed to pause its pale skin
flecked with droplets of blood thanks to
the sheer number of guards and
researchers it had torn through for
daring to look at it I see you're still
having the same old troubles the reality
warper continued reacting eerily calmly
and casually towards the Towering
monster you know you really ought to
work on your confidence that did it the
sentence touched a nerve within the shy
guy giving it a Pang of sadness that
erupted quickly into an unbridled rage
it did not matter that scp-343 was a
powerful anomaly with the ability to do
almost anything he had still looked at
scp-096 in fact he was looking directly
at and that meant he had to go his fate
was sealed as the creature began wailing
and charging straight for scp-343 with a
casual wave of his hand God swiped the
creature aside sending scp-096 flying
thrown telekinetically much to its
surprise the creature found itself
phasing through walls as it sailed
between corridors and other containment
Chambers in and out in and out until it
sailed through the solid steel walls of
its own cell Landing right back in the
corner that it had started in but rather
than returned to crying in a fetal
position as it normally did
scp-096 got right back up and raced back
through the halls of the facility homing
in on scp-343 being sent back to its
room was enough to keep the Shy Guy's
rage State active and it hadn't changed
the fact that God had still looked at it
so he had to kill him traveling at
anomalous speeds scp-096 blinked into
existence right behind scp-343 as he sat
down and relaxed in his favorite chair
the horrific humanoid shrieked loudly
although scp-343 didn't turn around to
look at it he already knew it was there
he had sensed it even before it left
itself with yet another lazy swish of
his hand
scp-343 sent the shy guy away this time
scp-096 realized its long legs seemed to
be moving independently walking
backwards along the exact same steps it
had taken to get into
scp-343's containment chamber it
continued going backwards and despite
its frustrated attempts to rush back
towards the reality warping old man it
couldn't little did the shy guy realize
it wasn't the only one
scp-343's command over the fundamental
laws of the universe was so great that
he had altered time itself everything
was now running in Reverse albeit for a
few short moments birds in the sky were
flying backwards waterfalls were flowing
upwards the Earth was spinning in the
opposite direction on its axis
everything in existence was like an old
VCR tape being rewound until
scp-096 found itself once again back in
itself now the shy guy was mad really
really mad the moment scp-343 allowed
time to return to its normal forward
chronological flow
scp-096 once again raced out of its
containment chamber hunting down the
latest person to have seen its why John
face usually nothing could stop scp-096
from catching up to its Target while
often killing them without fail but the
fact that scp-343 could so easily rework
the rules of the universe to send it
back to its room made the self-conscious
creature all the more agitated and it
was only going to get worse and worse
scp-096 kept trying infamously
Relentless but every time scp-343
presented some new unpredictable way of
stopping the shy guy from getting to him
on one attempt he caused the creature's
atoms to rearrange themselves into long
strands the closer it got effectively
turning into Shy Guy's spaghetti during
another
scp-343 actually reworked the way that
sight Works across the entire universe
making it so that on a conceptual level
he technically never looked at scp-096
according to this newly redefined way of
seeing things every time scp-343 set the
shy guy back but never deterred him he
kept coming back that is until bored by
the constant back and forth between them
scp-343 waited for scp-096 to arrive
next to him once again at that moment he
snapped his fingers and the creature
stopped in its tracks a story filled its
mind the story of a once normal kid this
young child had been bullied and
ostracized by their children made fun of
for his appearance they became depressed
self-loathing keeping away from everyone
out of fear that they'd be taunted the
child started to hide their face
desperate that nobody look at them and
laugh loosen
scp-343 told scp-096 there was nothing
around them the universe had seemingly
faded away as the pair stood in a pocket
of space outside of reality just listen
closely silence not a whisper not even
the creature's own breathing could be
heard no one is laughing at you anymore
my son
scp-343 whispered it is okay you can
stop now there is nobody left who can
hurt you with that
scp-096's very reason for being had
ceased the shy guy didn't exist anymore
it didn't need to restoring the universe
to its previous state with another click
of his fingers
scp-343 was free to sit back in his
chair and relax there he could continue
pretending he wasn't in control now go
check out scp-343 God vs Bill Cipher
from Gravity Falls and scp-096 tail a
lesson in power for even more SCP